hey guys it's Justine and today we have
got an incredible unboxing for you today
we're gonna be going over some of
Walmart's of Black Friday deals recently
I was on Good Morning America with
Walmart and we were talking about all of
these incredible products if you guys
missed it I would put a link in the
description if you want to watch the
segment oh my god last item is here
thank you this could quite possibly be
one of my favorite deals oh my goodness
a huge thank you to Walmart for
sponsoring this video Black Friday
starts on Walmart calm on Wednesday
11:27 at 10 p.m. Eastern in store Black
Friday starts on Thursday 11 28th at 6
p.m. your local stores time there's also
special Black Friday buy nail deals
starting today on Walmart calm while the
supplies last I'll also put a link in
the description so be sure to check it
out we're gonna start with this this is
a hoverboard plus a go kart combo I am
honestly so in shock because I remember
the whole hoverboard craze a few years
ago and these things were so expensive
so not only are you getting a hoverboard
but you're also getting a go-kart combo
it has LED lights six and a half inch
tires seven miles per hour at six miles
per charge oh boy this is gonna be great
I'm opening this one first so I can get
this all charged up and take it out for
a little ride
oh I'm opening it wrong
I love birthday here's the seat softer
cushion here's a good backrest is like
I'm gonna charge this up and while this
charges I'm gonna box something else
what are you doing
you this is soft you like to you know
the hoverboard is charging and now it's
time to unbox some more stuff next up
we've got the Crosley Cruiser is crazy
bit vinyl is making such a comeback and
what's great about this is it's small
it's portable it comes in multiple
colors and it's only $30 this one is
really pretty it's a nice like purple
lavenderish color I also have some
records here to test it out
have this nice little suitcase style
which makes it extremely portable whoa
it's actually really soft made of like
this velvet material I didn't get a
chance to see this up close when I was
in Good Morning America it was already
open and set up I'm really liking this
it's so soft it also has a headphone
jack just in case you want to have a
private listening experience of your
vinyl let's plug this in give it a try
I'm trying to not touch it
[Music]
this is old tech for me and I'm learning
let's test out the Bluetooth so I just
went in and connecting to bluetooth so
right here it found the Crosley I'm good
that must mean I'm connected so now I'm
going to play a YouTube video of my own
this is my last year video I did with
Walmart what do we have up next this
next one pretty excited about this is
the instant pot air fryer so you guys
may be familiar with instant pot duo
they've got all kinds of amazing
appliances but this is an air fryer
let's see what's in here
spoiler alert we're gonna make french
fries this is $49 I was just checking my
prices
that's actually pretty shocking 6 quarts
vortex four-in-one
airfryer rose to bake and reheat healthy
and tasty this is kind of great because
I love fried to it but obviously the
health benefits are not the best so with
this you're crying with air instead of
like oils and you're avoiding all of
those unhealthy fats
Oh friend Finn cut fries we're gonna
airfryer slash roast 14 to 18 minutes
and we're going to set the temperature
to 385 degrees Fahrenheit
shake partway therefore I am roast I can
just adjust it
385 so we're preheating this is going o
add food right now right right now you
want me to add the food okay okay oh my
gosh it's already the time the timer has
carted fries are in I went for 18
minutes and it says to shake partway
through so in a few minutes I'm gonna
give it a little shake while the fries
are airfryer we're gonna unbox some of
the other things that we have let's
start with the good will whole mini
these things are so great because
they're so small and they're compact and
you can basically put them anywhere
around the house and Walmart's Black
Friday price for this is $19 that's
amazing
this looks so great I love these things
they're just so small so you can
basically like put them anywhere in your
house I mean obviously a lot of people
know what this is but if you don't know
it just kind of looks like a little
decoration I love this thing it's so
great because it uses
you have any type of smart tech in your
house you can basically use your voice
to control your home you could also play
music and you can ask Google any types
of questions regarding whether you can
make phone calls all kinds of things and
these price feels so good this is
incredible I'm cooking in my living room
right now Tala do you think this is
something you could take with you
camping if you have power yeah
next up this is amazing this is the
Nintendo switch and this is $2.99 this
is the Mario Cart Nintendo switch bundle
obviously you guys know I absolutely
love Mario Kart I've had Mario Cart
parties I even had Mario come to my
house before by far one of the most
amazing things ever so with this you get
the Nintendo switch and you've the full
game that can be downloaded
ten minutes left on our prize look at
this we've got the to Joy cons and this
is actually the new Nintendo stitch and
this comes with all of the accessories
that you would need by far one of my
favorite accessory is this turns your
joy cons into a little controller so you
just pop them in there also like a dock
to
this is amazing pretty great Black
Friday deal
the fries are almost done they might
need a shake I got a check on them seven
minutes left these I think are almost
done oh it smells so good
do we have any salt over here no added
salt what I'm just gonna test one of
them
there really isn't we're gonna just okay
let me test it I think it actually might
be done oh my god they're gone they're
definitely done let's check these fries
oh these look great
[Music]
Jenna you better get hyped for fries
fries are done let's add another dash of
simple salt and let's try them okay dude
your button shut up get over here hasn't
fries do you know that french fries are
my favorite hey Google who invented
french fries Belgium here's a summary
from the website Wonderopolis org
the origins of the french fry have been
traced back to Belgium to find out more
look for the link in your google home or
google assistant app we can whatever we
want in here we can roast we can reheat
we could bake generally what pizza in
there it is four in one you can put
beads on it because I saw I saw the box
they had a piece of pizza no way yeah so
this french fries were incredible uh
they were really great and I cannot wait
to cook some more things in this now it
is time to go out and test the
hoverboards although the on TV again
this is a hundred and ninety eight
dollars this is a 4k Roku TV I showcased
this on Good Morning America and it was
really great now let's head outside
[Music]
this is so much fun I was actually
pretty surprised how quick this is
because I just remember these being
really not very fast this has a nice
speed to it the balance feels really
good Oh hoverboards what they're so fun
go-kart is all set up I guess I'm gonna
I guess hop on it and figure this out
okay getting on the hoverboard and
go-kart two and one
okay oh this is actually way more fall
gosh okay this is way more fun than I
thought it was gonna be oh oh my
goodness I've always wanted to be the
coolest kid at the park okay I'm feeling
really good like look how talented I am
I mean but I think I'm gonna do there's
a ramp over there
I'm gonna go launch off of it well I'm
not but oh my gosh okay whoa whoa whoa
I'm dizzy
oh I think I need a whole fleet of these
for all my friends this was so much fun
I hope you guys enjoyed this video I had
the best time reviewing some Walmart's
Black Friday deals if you guys want more
information be sure to check out Walmart
comm for more on our Black Friday deals
and I look forward to shopping Black
Friday but right now I'm gonna go home
bye
[Music]